alors celle qui fait la une de ce couple
aujourd'hui nous l'avons connu
adolescentes dans les années 60 avec des
jupes au dessus des genoux et puis
plaindre email sous les yeux on l'a aimé
dans les années 70 c'était déjà une
jeune femme avec des jeans avec des
cheveux dans le dos avec un sac en osier
sur la poitrine
et puis depuis le début des années 80
elle se dirige vers des films un peu
plus difficile et puis elle s'est même
risqué au théâtre l'année dernière un
jouet marivaux et vous verrez que
l'adolescente finira par être une grande
dame voici jane birkin
bonjour alors jen tu rentres de londres
où tu allais au festival de londres
présentait deux films d'as de mario
ancelle et puis les vols faire de john
reid
oui exactement exactement comment
s'est-elle angleterre alors un city
c'est bizarre pour moi parce que c'est
comment l'angleterre de thatcher
ben c'est surtout que je retourne
toujours pour mes parents pour pour mon
frère pour ma soeur pour les raisons
familiales toujours parfois plutôt
triste et toujours systématiquement en
tout cas peau pour garder le contact
avec ma famille presque tous les mois ça
c'était le première fois ont presque ont
presque 18 ans maintenant que je suis
retourné pour une raison professionnelle
alors c'est un plaisir oui ça me fait
plaisir que mes parents quelque chose
qu'ils ont la preuve que j'ai fait une
film sérieux qu'ils étaient 2 donc avec
java web qui est leur héros national
comme acteur et c'est john ging ou du
dans livres offerts
bien sûr alors je suis content pour ça
oui mais au début de temps c'est de ton
séjour en france
est-ce que tu as souffert d'être d'être
étrangère est ce que tu as tu as connu
la difficulté d une travailleuse
immigrée finale bon maintenant je crois
qu'il ya des sélections dont les
travailleurs immigrés et je ne sais pas
si les anglais ont fait partie non moi
je suis arrivé en 68 69 où justement les
anglais étaient
ce qui était des érables à cause de la
mode continue et les mini jupes les
cheveux rick gorne vers le bistrot oui
oui alors je crois que j'en ai profité
d'une suite d'instructions qui en
angleterre était parfaitement banal mais
pour vous j'avais l'air exotiques
quand tu t'es battu pour le féminisme tu
t'es battu contre la semaine à tulle
enfin je vais militer et dix ans quand
le quand la peine de mort maintenant je
mange l'apartheid oui et finalement
tu te bats beaucoup pour le respect des
droits humains pour le respect de la
personne humaine pour le respect des
droits de l'homme et on voit un clip en
ce moment la télévision où on voit ta
fille charlotte qui chante avec son père
une chanson sur l'inceste est ce que tu
n'es pas choqué par ça finalement
il n'est pas nous absolument pas je
trouve le chant sont très beaux et c'est
je compte vraiment de ce que vous pouvez
imaginer quelqu'un d'être et qui serait
très choqué de donner une idée choquant
sur lui et ça fait non je crois que
c'est une chanson d'amour qui est en
train de battre les records de gtm non
plus etc j'ai rencontré quelqu'un d'être
et de très près respectables se chope
nous au contraire non je trouve ça très
très beau un peu déroutante quelque part
comme j'entends du genre et si courageux
parce que moi je crois que ça m'a pris
ouf très longtemps pour pouvoir lancer
comme ça comme voler comme ça avec
puissance
elle a le don et le courage le faire à
14 ans du même que je suis très fière
d'elle dans le dernier film de 1000 r
oui comment il veut grobert oui mais où
elle fait de l'épreuve d'un trait d'un
très grande actrice
alors je suis fière d'elle très bien tu
milites beaucoup n'a pas beaucoup de
blanc n'a pas du tout mais moi je me
demande si finalement au bout d'un
moment le public en voyant chaque fois
des stars qui milite pour 6 pour ça est
ce que finalement il va pas y avoir en
rejet de la part du public exemple
disque que j'ai fait à la demande allait
stone age et m'a téléphoné en me
demandant de si je pouvais chanter avec
d'autres femmes pour les femmes des
enfants de youtube et finalement une
samedi matin c'était dit moi je me suis
dit je ne veux pas réfusé de de chanter
de petit couplet dans cette chanson ça
me semblait le moins des choses à la
prise de cette façon là on fait des
choses et c'est minime cdc des choses
minuscules si on vous demande votre
signature pour investi si on vous
demande de chanter ça je sais pas pour
vendre un paquet de lessive vous pouvez
vendre et non si pour quelque chose de
plus grave on peut vous l'utilisez bien
sûr vous allez à voile et les gens qui
qui contre attaque ou ou 10 comme quand
vous avez dit dès que certains qu'on
s'en lasse on peut sur le feu mais je
pense qu'il faut prendre de risques
dessin très bien merci beaucoup de
jeunes et maintenant on va voir on va
passer au sujet justement on va voir
cette chanson est enregistrée avec 26
autres chanteuses pour venir aux mains
si elle était très bien parce que je
savais pas lire le très beau moi je
savais pas chanter aussi bas finalement
c'est une d'entre elles qui est venu en
disant chante plus où je crois que ça
serait plus jolie pour toi il y avait
une grande chance de il n'y a pas un mot
pour fraternité féminin pour etc règne
le sororité seurot rites et de la
sororité merci héros malheureux